thank you Yasser we are with Hans Neiman
after an incredible Victory with the
black pieces against a fellow Junior
Christopher you Hans first of all let's
address the elephant in the room you've
been under a lot of pressure tell us a
bit about that
well um I think that this game is a
is a message to everyone and you know
this entire thing started with me saying
chess speaks for itself and I think this
game spoke for itself and showed the
chess player that I am and it also
showed that um I'm not going to back
down and I'm going to play my best chess
here regardless of the pressure that I'm
under and that's all I have to say about
this game and
you know
chess speaks for itself you know that's
all I can say let's discuss the game a
little bit that's it but uh you know you
can leave it to your interpretation but
thank you that is that's it all you want
to say yes because it was such a
beautiful game I don't even need to
describe it
thank you
right that's it
okay
I actually had one question if we're
still in studio I guess not no I mean
because it's disappeared but I wanted to
ask about the Knight takes D5 moment I I
don't think he wanted to speak I answer
uh the Knight takes D5 he came into the
studio and he said we're not going to
analyze the game I just want to say
something and that was it okay it was a
message for the world and he spoke with
his moves today